I split life
as we know it history into two eras so I
think there's the era of old trans and
the era of new Trans and the era of old
Trends goes up to about 2017 I'd say
around that period and then new the year
of new Trans is everything after that
and these are two wildly different uh
ways of looking at the trans experience
so
up until 2017.
um the way that we thought of the trans
experience was
like if you it wouldn't have been like
because I lived in Brighton as I say I
live in Brighton and you would sometimes
see a fellow in a dress ten years ago 15
years ago
but if you'd spoken to him at the time
you said like um oh you know why you why
are you wearing a dress he might say
well
I know I'm a man but like I feel more
comfortable in women's clothes and I've
always related to women and I always you
know I've always identified with women
um but then when the shift happened
around 2017 people went from saying that
they identify with women so I identify
it as a woman and so we went from saying
I feel like something to I am something
and the repercussions of that that
little shift affect literally everything
like it is all the entire problem that
we have now is
all down to the shift and I can give you
Myriad examples but like the so I mean
we had Marcus Evans on the show a
whistleblower from the Tavistock he'd
been there for like 35 years
um you know consultant psychotherapist I
think and he said you know like
in the old days you know before this big
shift and everything if someone comes in
saying you know I'm really distressed
you know like I I feel like trapped in
the wrong body or whatever the treatment
pathway for them was exploratory therapy
so it's like
um let's look at your life in the round
let's look at
um you know your relationship with your
parents relationship with your peers
um has there been any abuse any trauma
um what are your expectations what
actually means to be a man or a woman in
the world well you know talk us through
that
um and all these different things and
they explore those things but when this
new kind of way of thinking of saying
it's your identity and it's who you are
rather than just feelings that you have
came in
you can't do that anymore because if
your gender
is who you are
um
and you it's not that you feel like a
boy you can't treat something that you
are yeah quite yeah I mean it's like
it because it would be transphobic it'd
be like or it'd be like
someone with Down Syndrome going to the
doctor they don't try to cure your Down
syndrome or they'll try and cure you of
being black it's just like I mean like
um because it's it's
not even your identity it's who you are
it's intrinsic to your
the thing so like
there's
in the old days it was seen as again the
reason I'm giving this to 2017 cut-off
point is because something strange
happened there I think it might be to do
with people needing to shore up their
sense of being a good person in the wake
of brexit and Trump very very polarizing
year 2016 and people were desperate to
kind of
I think
no commits themselves and others that
they were on the right side and this was
the thing that came along and and you
have certain things that came along
around that time like India Willoughby
former guest of the show was on
Celebrity Big Brother in 2018. I'm a
real woman Amanda I want you to know
that yeah a real woman okay I'm glad
that's sinking here I'm going to say one
more time so it really penetrates I am a
real woman okay and then obviously
around that time you see the emergence
of the phrase like trans women are women
and and so and in fact if you think
about it when was the last time you
heard someone say identify as a woman
they don't do it anymore they don't even
say that anymore so it so it identifies
even dropped so so now it's it's who you
are and as I say so once yeah I thought
so when I read time to think the the
book about the Tavistock
I thought I had this idea in my head
that
the kids are coming along to the
Tavistock being referred and
there must be some like it it can't just
be that they rubber stamped them and
said oh you know puberty blockers
there's adults in the room it's all not
the way that people say in the media
it's all being properly you would think
that because you're like this is a place
of clinicians it's on the NHS it's being
overseen there's no way and you read the
book and you're like oh flip it actually
was like that like there was so much
intervention from
from like mermaids and other like
politicized bodies and such a culture of
fear
um that they were literally just being
like
okay uh well they had this thing called
this model called gender affirming care
which is
um you know an orwellian sort of uh uh
twisting of words really because you
know it's like you know to really affirm
someone it would be to say you're you're
brilliant just the way you are and you
don't need to change it then you don't
need to try and fit into these sex
stereotypes and you know you go for it
but anyway so this affirming care which
comes in with this idea of it's who you
intrinsically are
um that
just made everything a problem it's sort
of solidified it and it became the gold
standard not just the gold standard of
care but like
the American Psychological Association
and all these top bodies said this is
the way to care and if you're not doing
that if you're just exploring it like in
the old days you're kind of casting
doubt on their identity and who they
intrinsically are and it's not that
they've got a problem they've just
discovered the truth of who they are
um and but but this this problem this
shift from I feel like to I am this old
Trends where thinking this new Trans way
of thinking has affected everything else
as well so it's not just
um you know autistic and gay and other
vulnerable children being
um treated because of this
um you know in my mind a massive medical
Scandal
um and medical neglect but it's also
um
we see it in every area like in terms of
women's spaces
um because again it's like old trans
you've got a man who you know he feels
like a woman he feels comfortable moves
clothes fine but it's not going in the
women's change rooms because he's not
entitled to he's not a woman but now
it's like well he is a woman and
therefore you know he's entitled to that
that space and this is why
this is why I think people a lot of
people just think I don't get this trans
argument like why can't we just Live and
Let Live and why can't they just
reconcile because it can't be reconciled
they can't believe right yeah it's a
conflict of Rights and so the only way
that we can deal with these problems is
by going back just a few years ago just
what like seven eight years ago wherever
to you know live and that live where
would you want call yourself what you
want like that's fine I don't mind I
don't care like no one cares how someone
dresses and chooses to live their you
know Express themselves but I'm sorry we
can't overreach into the area of you
actually are this
foreign